let's go to David from Florida David
from Florida uh what's going on I may be
making my uh triumphant return to
Florida very soon
pretty added usually at the Miami area
ah okay it's a little too crowded for
for my case
um
I just had uh two questions for you sure
uh one your opinion on the fact that it
seems neither of the parties are going
to be participating in uh debates at
least at least the Republican conference
did say that you know they would have
one it's just Trump may not be
participating uh but the fact that Biden
doesn't even want to talk to
um Marianne or Kennedy kind of seems a
little messed up to me yeah I mean
listen
um I would like to see debates on both
sides I think Trump not showing up is
pathetic and I think that the DNC
um should organize debates but I'm also
not naive obviously why if you are if
you have an incumbent president and you
have as a priority making the incumbent
president president for four more years
why would you take the risk and I know
people say well if it were Obama there
would be less risk because Obama's
better and speak public speaking than by
whatever why would you create a
situation with the risk that your
eventual nominee ends up hurting
themselves with a bad debate performance
it's sort of like obviously I I'm always
for debate and more conversation but
it's also so obvious that it would be a
completely unforced risk for the DNC to
to try to force Biden to debate
and even uh his you know age and the
fact that he has uh seemingly more
difficulty to speak uh not that you know
he doesn't get anything done he does
it's just it's a little bit more public
appearances you know it's not doing as
good as he used to yeah but it's not
it's not because I mean the when you
have an incumbent uh running for
reelection
you don't do debates
if he does go to debate and he gets he
gets you know troused it just makes him
you know look even worse as the
incumbent so people would be more likely
to you know vote otherwise right I
completely understand what you're saying
yeah all right my second thing was oh
about uh the Florida Senate Bill 7050
where they slipped in the fact that you
can now uh run for other office uh if
you're running for the presidency
I actually did not see that but I know
that there was a discussion of changing
that and of course it's specifically for
um for Ron DeSantis yeah I didn't I
actually didn't see that that passed
yeah fairing cousins actually just did a
video about it
um it was last Friday I believe that
they put it through of course behind
closed doors saying that you know if you
were to run for office and other you
know other offices like that would you
know you'd have to uh resign first
resign to run
um and then they put in if you're going
for the presidency nah that's totally
cool go for it yeah well I mean listen
we all know the whole point of that I
still don't know a hundred percent
whether DeSantis is or isn't going to
announce I mean I think he probably will
but I think it's possible he'll get
talked out of it but it's very clear
that they're setting the stage for him
to run if he wants to
well we can we can only hope that he
does it might pull away a little bit of
uh some Republican votes but uh we'll
we'll see what happens in 24. thanks for
taking my call all right David from
Florida there he goes let's go next to
LJ from Las Vegas LJ from Las Vegas
welcome to the program what's on your
mind
hey David how you been doing well
good
um I have a kind of a rough cut on
something so it's not 100 thought
through but I just kind of want to get
your thought on it if that's cool sure
um so I know that we always talk about
like every single year um the black
community being a very big part of the
democratic party and like one of the
most reliable voting blocks for you know
Democrats in a sense yes I kind of
wondered what some of the things that we
can do at because I'm Hispanic myself
right to activate more Hispanic people
more you know Mexicans more Cubans more
um just the the Block in general to kind
of create more you know um
discussion around like you know opening
the border for people who are good you
know and again this is again a rough cut
of an idea so I just kind of want to get
your point of view on that well here's
the thing one of the things that I try
to resist is assuming that in order to
get a certain group involved you need to
cater or Pander with particular issues
above and beyond the general idea that
there are all sorts of different reasons
why they should be engaged with politics
now obviously we can't ignore that
different groups have different
priorities so if a population that is
more likely to have family in Central
and South America is almost certainly
going to be more motivated by certain
issues than people that don't and that
might relate to everything from
so-called chain migration to DACA
permanent status all these different
things but one of the things I think is
really important is if we identify not
necessarily a group but people who
aren't engaging politically
first we should be having a general
conversation about why aren't you
engaged why aren't you voting whatever
the case may be before automatically
jumping to like for example if there
were a bunch of say uh gay men who
weren't voting I wouldn't necessarily go
straight in on LGBT rights for example I
would first just want to know why aren't
you why aren't you engaged because the
reason they're not engaged may actually
not be related specifically to issues of
LGBT rights and obviously it's important
to say hey it might be of particular
importance for you to get involved
because right now one party actually
wants to strip right specifically from
folks based on an identity that you
share but I would start with the more
General reasons to be involved
politically
um definitely it's just it's interesting
because as someone who grew up here in
Vegas right um in Nevada it's 20 of uh
the population is Hispanic right
um and within Nevada state um
accordingly to the Census Bureau so you
know I don't know how accurate that is
but that's at least the numbers that I
can record yeah I don't have them in
front of me I'll take a word for it
yeah um but um in that sense right um I
do feel like there's always this
assumption that the Hispanic Vote or at
least in my personal view that
um people don't think it's as important
or as valued as let's say the black Vote
or the mothers in Suburban neighborhoods
right and my thought is why couldn't
there be a discussion more to include
um Hispanic families um Nevada or Elise
Las Vegas has one of the best unions in
the entire country right The Culinary
Workers Union Yes and I feel like as
Hispanics that's a very big thing that
we should be focusing on is increasing
the size of that Union and using Nevada
as a template for why unions should work
across the country I agree 100 and I as
a you know I was born in Argentina moved
to the U.S Hispanic immigrant et cetera
I agree with you 100 that it is a group
that
um I think should be it's not a question
of targeting but understood more
um and I I completely agree with
everything you're saying
cool thank you I appreciate it Dave all
right LJ from Las Vegas there he goes uh
let's go to oh I don't know how about uh
how about Chris from Texas Chris what's
going on today
can you hear me yes I can
David yes
can you hear me yes
can you hear me yes I can
okay okay so I guess one thing I was
having a question about was what are
your thoughts on the Jordan Neely death
you know I saw that um Eric Adams so
this is the death of uh this was a man
who was kill correct me if I'm wrong
Chris this is a man who was killed on a
New York City subway basically put in a
choke hold for like 10 minutes or
something like that after yeah 15 15
minutes you know and I want to be
careful here after maybe acting sort of
aggressively but it's like not really
totally clear right I mean I think that
this is kind of what there's debate over
and I saw Eric Adams the mayor of New
York City put out a statement that was
kind of quite weird just very
generically condemning tragedy but
um talking about mental illness and
things that are not not even totally
clear I I don't I'm kind of reserving
judgment because I just want to learn
more about it I read a couple stories
about it and I saw some statements but I
don't want to say anything wrong until I
know more
yeah I guess for me it just makes me
kind of a little worried just because I
I guess for me I'm black and autistic as
well and I feel like I a lot of the
times when it comes to mental health our
country doesn't really do much service
for people that are in need of mental
health treatment or or who have or or
who are in poverty as well and I kind of
feel like some of the policies that Eric
Adams has done when it comes to like
increasing police funding while cutting
like Social Services like for education
and likes and and health and health and
Healthcare and housing is kind of
probably exacerbated the problem in my
opinion well listen what I don't want to
do is to start characterizing the
incident as anything other than than
what it is it has the potential to
basically be a sort of vigilantism that
we should be extremely concerned about
it it has the possibility of being a
mental illness story as well I just I
just want to know more it is a tragedy
without a doubt but I want to know more
details before I kind of like give what
might be a more definitive take about it
but uh from what I've read and seen so
far extraordinarily concerning
yeah but I guess Also regarding
vigilance vigilanteism how can we
probably address like like with laws to
prevent more vigilante justice because I
feel like it's been getting out of hand
like especially I remember there was
this one kid who was shot from a what
from a white old white guy in from some
other state as well yeah the issue with
vigilantism is that it it
directly relates to
how self-defense laws are written and
enforced and that can include stand your
ground castle doctrine Etc so it really
comes down to state law on a lot of
those issues and you deal with people
people's willingness to participate in
vigilantism is going to directly relate
to their understanding of self-defense
law uh in their state and so that's the
context in which it needs to be thought
through
so probably we'll need to do something
more along the lines of trying to
educate people better in terms of how
self-defense laws work and also trying
to maybe change the voting the the laws
regarding self-defense as well
potentially potentially and it depends
on state to state yeah Chris thank you
for bringing it up I appreciate it
all right thank you for the call David
all right there goes Chris from Texas
thanks for uh calling in today we're
going to take a quick break and the
Thursday show is going to continue